[Music]
alright this is a segment where viewers
try to find mistakes on our show yeah
incredible right this finely crafted gem
yeah it's pretty obvious that this thing
is perfect yes well so far hundreds of
challengers over the last couple of
years
not one winner no one has found a
mistake
well tonight a fan named michael jane
says he thinks he caught a mistake
he says it happened when I was talking
about a certain celebrity recently I'm
gonna make this quick you screwed up how
you screwed up really bad you
mispronounce somebody's name Alec
Baldwin announced he's officially
retiring from public life that's right
Shia LaBeouf made a similar announcement
a couple of weeks ago direct your
attention to this celebrity
pronunciation website Shia LaBeouf Shia
LeBouf shallow buff American actor
pronunciation Shia okay last name haha
good Shia LaBeouf not Charlotte booth
that's a jump me
[Applause]
well it's hard to argue with that man
about anything yeah no he's uh he's
clearly got the upper hand before the
debate even begins well sorry Michael
but you are dead wrong his name is
pronounced LeBouf not LaBeouf it turns
out your online research is flawed
here's a video we received in the mail
that proves I'm correct hey Mikey meet
your cousin Jake sitting in your crappy
apartment I set up that fake celebrity
pronunciation website knowing you'd fall
for it and send Conan a fan correction
why to prove to the world what a dumb
ass you are enjoy your next roof's buff
sandwich gets me killed meat out of my
cousin that challenge still stands if
you think you've spotted an error on our
show report it at team koco.com slash ha
ha I found an error we will sort it out
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chummy doubt of
the maestro go
[Applause]